so first of all congrats on the series
and I sincerely hope it's a huge hit but
before we get into this I like throwing
a curveball at the beginning all right
besides Echo if someone has never seen
anything you've done before what is the
first thing you'd like them watching and
why H do you have an idea I kind of do
but it's just sort of like a weird yeah
um um the English sure I'll go with
that I mean I I heard I heard about that
one yeah I heard Emily Blunt character I
think she's okay the up and comer yeah
yeah she's got a good future yeah I
would say uh probably the very first
feature film I did uh back in the day um
where I was a lead called rhymes for
young ghouls yes if you haven't seen it
see that movie it's really good thanks
yeah yeah jumping into why I get to talk
to you guys something that really
surprised me about the show was that
this is not your typical Disney plus
Series this is more Netflix than Disney
Plus in terms of what you get away with
so can you sort of talk about the fact
that this is more an adult more for an
older audience yeah yeah well it's
darker it's gritty um a lot of people
get killed uh it's violent um but
there's a story there and what I like is
that it's it's about family but it's
also about trauma and I think all
families no matter what Walk of Life you
have that in your history and I think
people can relate to that and also she's
just a badass character you know that's
pretty much it sure yeah I I think that
Echo well it marks the first TV MA
rating for all Marvel shows and so I
think with that it means we get to go
deeper and we get to hit harder I think
that there's a a grittiness and and a
brutality to it that we really get to
feel the weight of Maya being a Crime
Boss that she is a killer that she's
somebody who who kills people for higher
like that's that's really dark and and
to have her as an anti-hero who rooting
for just gives it um gives it an edge
that I don't know um has been explored
as much in in the MCU sure um when you
saw the shooting schedule what is the
thing that you saw what day did you see
and be like I cannot wait to film this
or oh my God how are we filming this oh
I would say for me it was the roller
skating rink that was a big one because
you see it on paper but I've done enough
movies where it's going to look
different and yeah and how are they
going to do that it was ambitious yeah
it was ious and I'm glad they were to
pull it off but you never know when
you're in the middle of film you never
really know until you see it on the
screen no 100% I think it's the finale
for me where the finale we can't talk a
whole lot about it right now but there
are or can
you there are cultural aspects to the
finale that kind of bring everything to
a head that involve ancestors that
involve um present day people and and so
I think that it's um looking at it on
paper on the script I was like how on
Earth are we going to film this but I
think it was done so beautifully by our
director Sydney Freeland who is just
like a rock star in all of it and I
don't think that we could have brought
it home with anyone else could it be
called a powwow I don't know you're
saying words and I'm sitting here right
well I mean you know I'm just throwing
that out there but I I did hear that the
way you guys filmed the power was very
respectful and that Marvel really went
above and beyond to make sure it was
something great well I don't think we're
giving anything away but it's uh it was
very authentic it's like yeah they
really went all out the other the stands
there people selling things the amount
of background performers from who were
flown from communities across North
America across Turtle Island it was a
lot of people and you think about the
the the people that got flown what a
great opportunity you know absolutely
yeah think to show their art I thought
it was really special too that um while
we're portraying chocked off people from
Oklahoma while we're filming it in um in
Atlanta and in Georgia that's like the
home territory of a lot of indigenous
folks from the trail of tier so it was
almost like a homecoming to be able to
bring a lot of people across Indian
Country into Georgia the place where
they were forcibly displaced from um so
it was it was really meaningful and I
think that it was um it was really
special and I was not referring to uh
set event but when I'm I think the thing
that was most ambitious that I was
curious how they were going to do it was
uh the the Great the grand Showdown
that's going to happen at some point
sure wait wait there there you're
telling me that at the end of a Marvel
show there's a big action setpiece that
involves a protagonist and Anton huge
spoiler this is shocking I have never
ever seen this before um so obviously
you guys are fans of Marvel if if you
had to pick and I'm putting you on the
spot what are like the three Marvel
films that you think everyone needs to
say I'll go with uh Iron Man and then
the uh AME game TR end game and you know
the last one the last two movies ofinity
war war yeah I would say those those are
powerful too it was pretty like when
Tony Stark dies I shed a tear
maners no J I think I think people know
yeah I'm gonna go a little off-kilter
I'm going to say ones that are not
necessarily the most popular I'm G to
say uh Thor Ragnarok as one of them I'll
say U moonight as another one of them
and then probably the third would be uh
shangi oh yeah I like the diversity of
the pics um so one of the things about
um family members I'm curious which of
your friends and family were actually
the most excited when you told them by
the way I'm going to be in the MCU or in
in Marvel my nephew my nephew yeah he
just went yeah he loved it he loved it I
we got those hats yeah I gave him I gave
him a hat he's going to wear that when
it PR years it's really cool it's really
cool feeling to like hey your uncle's in
this I think the person who is most
excited for me is my dad dad who I also
gave a hat to um but yeah it was
definitely my dad cuz I think he just
wants me to be an action figure I think
that's that's his like dream for me is
to be an action figure so we'll see if
bunny becomes that would be cool that
would be really cool um I think that the
the you know the pops the Funko Pops
they make Funko Pops for so I would
imagine that that is a real possibility
oh we've been fully scanned like yeah
yeah we got SC but every time we finish
the scene we have to go get scanned
anyway listen congrats on the show I do
hope it's a huge hit for you guys and I
wish you nothing but the best thanks man
thank you so
much